that's not about the show powerless okay
you if you want no one ever talks that
way in a talk show why I don't know I
like I like what you're doing I just
wish more people did it okay yeah all
right that's all that Kurt Russell he
brought you a gif and I didn't know that
we were all bringing home a gift so I
brought you two it's just I don't have
my own wine or anything but I got this
hand turkey that I made you know this is
such a it's a funny show you one of the
pluses of this show is that you play a
character named Ron that is helpful I
saw I was watching one scene where you
got you were cursing out this old white
woman oh just were and you were really
tearing her apart you see old white
woman what was what's it what's to shoot
that scene it's personally a dream come
true it's a trick I kept shooting it
being like there's no way they're gonna
put this on television they don't
normally allow a large black man to yell
at old white ladies on TV dad I thought
I think that was illegal up until 1968 I
love that I got the yell at her and
people thought it was funny and I was
like oh man I must be really charming
[Laughter]
you